SAIF RAYYAN: Welcome, everyone.
Hi.
This is our J-WEL panel
titled Tips from Teachers
on Moving Laboratory
Experiences Online.
My name is Saif Rayyan, and
I'm the Assistant Director
of Academic Programs at J-WEL.
I'm joined here by my
colleague, Kirky DeLong.
Kirky, can you say hi?
KIRKY DELONG: Hello, everybody.
Thank you for being
with us today.
We're glad to have
you here, and it's
going to be a wonderful panel.
SAIF RAYYAN: Absolutely.
I'm really excited about
the number of people
that are joining us here.
We're also excited about
the panel of speakers
that are joining us.
They're an experienced group
of educators and innovators
in teaching and learning.
And they've been
working on improving
laboratory experience in person
or online for many years.
And suddenly, as we all try
to move our teaching online,
they've been also
dealing with this
but using the same tools
and maybe more tools
than they've used before.
They're going to tell us
more about their experiences.
So we hope this will
be a discussion.
Please bring up your questions
and who you are or where,
who's everyone and
where they come from,
which country,
what do you teach?
And as our speakers
introduce themselves
and present some of
their work, please
put any questions in chat.
We will wait for the
questions until after all
the presentations.
But Kirky's going to work on
compiling all the questions,
and we're going to
have quite a discussion
after all the presentations.
It's my pleasure to
introduce our panel.
Peter Bohacek is a Physics
Teacher and a Co-founder
of Pivot Interactives.
Dr. John Liu is a Lecturer
in Department of Mechanical
Engineering at MIT.
Oh, you guys want
to say hi, Peter?
PETER BOHACEK: Yeah.
Hello.
Nice to see everybody here.
It's wonderful to see
such a great collection.
And thanks for the--
I'm watching the chat scroll by.
Great to see people
from so many places.
JOHN LIU: It's a
pleasure to meet you all.
I'm looking forward to
a fantastic discussion,
especially with these very
experienced colleagues.
SAIF RAYYAN: Great.
And Jeannie Talbot
from California.
Thank you, Jeannie
for accommodating us.
And it's very early there.
JEAN TALBOT: Yeah.
Thanks for having me.
Yeah, it's early, but this
is a really good panel.
I'm looking forward to what all
of the other panelists will say
and looking forward to
sharing what I've got.
SAIF RAYYAN: Absolutely.
And Bruce Van Dyke from
Quincy College Biotechnology
and Manufacturing
Practice program.
BRUCE VAN DYKE: I'm
glad to be here.
It's great to see
all the people that
are so interested in
trying to figure out
what the best tools are
for whatever your need is.
And I'm glad to be able
to present what we've
been doing at Quincy College.
SAIF RAYYAN: Thank you, all.
So first, I'll give the
floor to Dr. John Liu.
John is the Lecturer on
Research in Mechanical Engineer
Department and a
Digital Learning Fellow.
I've known John for many years.
We worked on some of
the physics courses
when he collaborated with us
in the Physics Department.
And some of them were actually
about laboratory experiences.
But then he moved on, and
he managed the MicroMasters
Program.
And now he's teaching
and researching
and currently is teaching MIT's
Design Manufacturing course.
I'm excited to learn about
how this whole transition
to remote learning in the
Mechanical Engineering
Department and in your course
specifically has been going.
JOHN LIU: Thank you so much.
Hello, everyone.
I'm so, so excited to be here.
Thank you again, Saif
and Kirky, for having me.
What I'd like to
share today really
stems from, you could say, our
experience of the past couple
of months of transitioning.
We were all shocked.
I still remember two months
ago when MIT pulled the plug,
and we realized
everything's going remote.
And we could think
through a lot of how
we were going to transition,
but we didn't really
know how to think
about transitioning
the lab in hands-on activities.
That really seemed
like a black hole.
We didn't know where to start.
So we've been-- I've
been in the trenches
now for a couple
months, and I'd love
to share a little bit about what
our department has been up to
and share with you some
of what we've learned.
And to start, so our
department, this term
we're teaching 30 labs
in project-based classes.
And we can really parse
all of the classes
into three buckets
using a very--
by asking a very
simple question--
where does the model exist?
Does the model exist on campus?
Does the model exist at home?
Or does the model exist
in the virtual space?
And to put some feet to this,
let me give you some examples.
So when the model--
if the model exists
on campus, usually we
found it's a scenario where the
equipment is fairly expensive,
or it's dangerous,
or it's hard to move.
It's large and heavy.
And it also was in cases when
the staff could be present.
So we had two types
of cases where
the model exists on campus.
One, you can pre-record
your own lab experiments
and talk through them.
But then, once you
have the recording,
you host a synchronous
discussion.
So you show your own
work, recorded work.
And you pause it
at different parts.
And you ask your students,
what should we do now, or what
about these different options,
or did you notice this or that?
There's also real-time.
So you notice that
I'm showing an SEM.
We literally outfitted an SEM.
It was already controlled
by a desktop computer.
But then we set it up so that
it could be controlled remote.
So students could control--
whether they're in
Indiana to India,
they can control the
computer and, therefore,
perform SEM experiments
from anywhere in the world.
There's another
iteration of this
where perhaps an instructor
puts a GoPro on their head
and has different
views from cameras.
And the instructors basically,
they act as the hands.
And they ask the students,
what should I do next?
And the students are
the ones who instruct.
And they talk through different
experiments or fabrication
processes.
When the model exists
at home, usually we're
talking about a scenario
where you can significantly
or meaningfully
reduce the complexity
and that you can handle
the logistics of shipping
and also the safety of students
actually interacting over these
without direct presence
from the staff.
So we had homegrown
type experiments
where students had
to go, and they
had to prototype
their own terrarium
as we were thinking about
food scarcity in the world.
We teach design by play.
And so students were using
foam, simple materials like foam
and balsa wood, to put together
prototypes of board games.
Here's one on
playing with islands.
So here, you're collecting
materials from or to home,
and then you're
assembling them at home.
Or we're sending kits directly
to the homes of each student.
So on the top here, we actually
sent commercial CNC Engravers
to each student that was taking
a Precision Machining Design
course.
Or for control and
dynamics, we sent--
we assembled kits, literally
from the contracting
the work of laser engraving,
and cutting aluminum struts,
and having vendors
send us wheels
that we could assemble
subassemblies and then send
them to students where they had
to assemble the subassemblies
and then code their own
microcontroller to learn
about feedback control and how
a Segway robot kit can still
remain and move, stand still,
when it's being controlled.
And then finally, if the model
exists in the virtual world,
often it's a scenario
where you already
have pre-existing virtual
resources that you
can translate to have
comparable activities that you
were doing on campus.
So especially for our
design or project courses,
here's a case where students
are designing robots.
And they usually
have to CAD anyway,
but they move very
quickly to take
that CAD to produce
blueprints to fabricate them
in the machine shop.
But now, with the extra time
and space we're allotted,
we've really focused on not just
CAD for form but the function,
focusing on the mating
between different parts,
focusing on tolerances
between how the parts fit
together and move.
And then, instead of then
prototyping and then testing,
does this prototype actually
fit the functional requirements
of my design, all of that can
be moved to the virtual space
if you have software packages.
So here's an example where,
in the class that I teach,
students have to
mass-produce yo-yos.
And instead of doing
that, here we have them,
through a software
package called Moldflow,
you're actually simulating the
flow of the plastic, the molten
plastic, into the yo-yo
molds that they already
designed originally
for the machine shop.
And then, instead
of actually thinking
through, how might I
rearrange the current machine
shop or a factory floor, we have
them simulate the manufacturing
system through Tecnomatix.
And there's a number of
different software packages
out there.
And so you have the practical
scenarios and constraints
that will guide your decisions.
But really, you want to think
about the other side, too,
the pedagogical side.
How do you link
the learning goals?
Really, that should
be the first question.
What are your learning goals,
and how do you prioritize?
And what do you
want the students
to get out of that lab
or hands-on activity?
Is it the synthesis
of a phenomenon
on nano, micro, macro scale?
Is it a design for prototyping?
Is it design for manufacturing?
Is it the analysis or
characterization of a process?
What do you want your students
to get out of an activity?
And then after that,
think through some
of the unique aspects
of hands-on learning,
the reasons why you wanted
them to have hands-on learning.
So for example, hands-on
learning is good because you
can't hand wave through all of--
hand wave away.
You just can see how those
cause outputs directly.
Or is it that you want
that physical layer
to break the often what's
bifurcated in students?
They do homework, and then
they throw all that out
when they look at
the real world.
You want to break that by
adding that physical layer.
Or is it there's
something special
that students learn when they
can feel and they can touch?
So how do you link --
what are your learning goals?
And how do you link
these different aspects
of hands-on learning to it?
Because what you
need to do is you
need to think about both sides.
You need to think about
the practical reasons,
the scenarios and constraints--
and I gave you an example,
different examples of those--
and also the pedagogical ones.
So each of these are going to
have different characteristics.
So if the model exists on
campus, then in general,
when you transition,
you're going
to see that you're
able to preserve most
of the real-world
aspects, because that
was the original context that
you designed those activities.
You can also capture the
same level of complexity.
But then people don't
feel things necessarily.
And often, there's
also a decreased amount
of interaction.
I mean, even in the case
with the remote control,
the staff had to load
the sample into the SEM,
the scanning electron
microscope, for example.
If the model exists
in the home, then you
can capture a lot of
the different aspects,
but you do have to significantly
reduce the complexity so
that it can be shipped
over or so that students
can handle them by themselves
without you next to them.
And then finally, if the model
exists in the virtual space,
a lot of software packages--
research, commercial--
they can be quite complex, and
there's a lot of input output.
But you may miss
the physical layer
because they're seeing something
that's simulated or analyzed.
And then finally, there's
a difference in this piece
that you have to think through,
where is that complexity?
So these are the different areas
that we found really came up
in our discussions when we were
thinking about that transition.
So first, safety.
If your model exists in campus,
then staff have to be there.
And you have to
think through, how
are you going to social
distance while you operate
the different activities?
Safety means something
different for home.
How are students going
to independently operate
the materials or equipment?
For the budget,
most of your budget
when the model
exists on campus is
going to go to setting up
whatever equipment that you had
and now transferring that over.
So if it's for remote control,
the hardware or the software
setup.
When it exists in the home,
kit materials and the shipping.
And then finally,
the software licenses
was probably the main--
what composed of the
lion's share of the budget
when we were talking
about the model
line in the virtual world.
You'll also be focusing
on different things.
A lot of our workload
in the first category
really went to going to set
up this real-time instruction
and real-time feedback.
If the model exists
in home, there
was incredible time spent
on the assembly of the kits
or making sure that
the instructions could
be followed when you're
not physically present.
And then finally, if the work--
if the model is in the
virtual space, a lot of time
was spent on, one, the staff,
us learning the new software.
We had to translate
the activities
into the software
package itself,
and then working with IT.
Your students are
going to experience
different limitations in
these different models,
as well, in these different
locations, as well.
Now obviously,
there's a lot of talk
about how students experience
bandwidth issues with Zoom
now, for example, that there
could be fuzzier audio.
But that's somewhat applicable
through all of these.
What I mean internet connection
when the model exists on campus
is real-time control has
an additional bandwidth
requirement.
And how are you going
to control something?
And if there's lag,
how is a student going
to see it in time to react?
When the model exists at home,
you have to think through,
how are the students going
to receive these packages?
Do they have the tools
to fabricate or measure?
And then, is there
even a stable space
where they can carry
out these activities
that they want to carry out?
When the model
exists in the cloud
or in the virtual, space
you have to think through,
do the students have the
personal computing resources
necessary to install
the software, the latest
and the greatest that
you want them to use?
Or is this something
that you have
to contract out, for
example, to Amazon computing?
But there's things that--
there's unique
opportunities that
are associated with all three.
We found that with labs
that are on campus, often
the person who is closest to
whatever you're demonstrating
gets a front row seat, but
everyone else, especially
the people all the
way in the back,
they don't really see anything.
When you share screen,
everyone sees the same thing.
And so there's a uniform
experience of the experiment
that you want them to
analyze and to consider.
On the learning opportunities
for these the model
laying in the home, there's
somewhat of an increased sense
of independence and agency.
Are they collecting the
materials around their home?
Are they walking
outside the home
and looking at the
world around them?
They have to connect a lot more
to their personal and physical
context.
And then finally, I
got a lot of feedback
from instructors that there
was a deeper sense of,
there was a tighter loop when
the model exists in virtual,
and you're simulating.
There's a tighter loop
between the inputs
that you're putting in and
then directly, how does that
cause changes in function,
or form, or phenomenon?
And so students were much
more able to really think
through the deeper contextual
understanding of whatever model
that you wanted them to think
about in the first place.
So I hope that framework helps
you to think through your own
just to combine pedagogical
and practical considerations.
Thank you so much.
And I'm looking forward
to the questions.
SAIF RAYYAN: Thank you, John.
This was a great introduction
to the different strategies
that you can actually
use at different levels.
I love your discussion
around the learning
and the pedagogical value.
What I'm getting out of this
is that probably the most
efficient is a combination of
all these methods in some form,
because some of them
provide opportunities
in different areas.
And one of the things that
we've been talking about
is that, even after
this crisis is over,
we will probably continue
using some of these methods
because they have
their own strengths.
And this is a good
transition into the rest
of the presentations
where we will focus more
on the virtual and the remote
part of the experience,
which where we're all
using more often now.
So the next speaker, next
panelist, is Peter Bohacek.
I'm so excited to
have Peter here.
I met Peter years ago at
the American Association
of Physics Teacher.
Peter is a physics
teacher in Minnesota,
but he's also the Co-founder
of Pivot Interactives.
He comes from an
industry background.
And first time he showed
me his interactive videos,
I was a believer.
I was like, this is
a fantastic resource.
I've not seen in a video--
video for me is very static.
There is not much engagement.
Sure, you can show
something that's fancy.
But he is able to use
the videos in a very
engaging, interactive
way, and he's
going to tell us more about it.
PETER BOHACEK: Great.
Thank you.
And John, thank you.
That introduction is
really a good overview.
And so it's a nice segue into
exactly what the affordance is
of interactive video.
And I particularly
appreciate the part
about deciding what the
learning goals are, because
for laboratory experiences
and for all teaching, that's
the starting point.
What are you hoping the
students to get out--
are going to get out of it?
So I'd like to share
my screen and show
about interactive video.
So interactive video, as
Saif said, video in general
can be a passive learning tool,
not that it can't be effective,
but with interactivity--
I'll just show you a
quick example and then
some of the different ways
that interactive video can
be used remotely and for
face to face learning
and for different
subject areas, as well.
So I'll just start
with this video here.
This is a high-speed
video filmed
of a stream of water, a
laminar flow fountain.
It doesn't look like
it's moving, but it is.
And a metal blade is
going to come and sever
this and cause a gap.
And so one of the first
things about interactive video
is it's engaging for students.
And this is something that
we've researched quite a bit.
And immediately, students
are fascinated by the motion
of the water, why it's so--
appears not to be moving
before and then suddenly
realize it is.
So then, to make it
interactive, what we have here
is a set of measurement tools.
So here, the students
can have a ruler
that they can use and
rotate to make measurements,
a protractor, stopwatch.
And so they are
[INAUDIBLE] decisions
about how and what
they're going to measure.
And in this
particular case, what
we're going to
ask students to do
is apply a model
for how objects move
under the influence of gravity.
And so they are going to
make a prediction about where
they think this gap in the water
is going to land as it travels
along out of the screen.
And so after they do
that, this is an example
of how we implement interactive
video in our Pivot Interactives
platform, where we have
a series of questions.
In this case, the students
make a prediction.
And then after they
do, this is exactly
the same event that
you saw up above,
the same laminar flow
fountain recorded
at exactly the same time.
You'll see the saw
blade pass through
and create that same gap.
But now the students
can find out
whether the prediction that they
made about where this is going
to land is accurate or not.
And also John mentioned,
one of the things
about the complexities,
the details,
the deviations from
simplified models.
And here, students
really get to do
that because the width
of the gap grows.
And so an added
question is, why?
And so, when you
made your prediction,
would it be more accurate to
say that it's for the leading
edge or the trailing edge?
And so immediately,
we get students
asking the kinds of questions
that, as educators, we
hope they will, far beyond an
equation for projectile motion.
But, how do these things
look in the real world?
So that's an example.
Besides things that
are very slow motion,
we also can do apparatus
that would normally
be difficult for the
students to have access to.
So in this case, we're
going to study conservation
of mechanical energy.
So we'd like to have
a frictionless ramp.
And so we use a
superconducting disk that
sits above a magnetic ramp.
And so now this can move
with very, very low friction.
So the students can see,
in this case, what they're
going to be asked to do is
develop a model, a model that
relates the release height.
So here, they can select
a different release height
and load a video, and then see,
how does that release height
affect the speed at the bottom?
So they'll make a little
speed trap here at the bottom,
use a stopwatch here.
So now they can measure
the speed at the bottom.
And they can also have
other measurement tools
that they use to measure
the release height.
And so then they can build
a model here and find,
what is the mathematical
relationship
between the height from
which it's released
and the velocity at the bottom?
So John was talking
about the goals
for, I think for a lot of people
as educators in science models,
developing models, testing
models, applying models.
And so in this
case, the students
are able to build a model
that finds that relationship.
I'll just quickly
show an example now
where they can test the model.
This is the same apparatus,
but now the video
shows that the puck is
going to get flicked.
But the video ends before
the puck gets very far.
And so the students are asked
this time to make a prediction.
Where will that puck
end up, up the ramp?
And after they make
the prediction, again,
like we saw in
the last one, then
the video is
revealed that allows
them to test whether
the prediction is right.
The two examples that I've shown
are in introductory physics.
Oh, I suppose this one is, too.
So this is an example
where, again, students
may not have access to.
In this case, what we
have is an authentic gold
medal from the
PyeongChang Olympics
and a fake gold medal from
the PyeongChang Olympics.
And both of them are subjected
to the same experiment.
They're immersed
in a tank of water.
And you can read
the scale reading.
And from that, the students
can determine not only
which is the actual
gold medal, but what
is a gold medal made out of?
So again, this is
the sort of thing
that interactive
video allows students
to see things they
may not otherwise
be able to interact with.
Also things that are very small.
In this case, this is
a chemistry activity
where students can
explore the surface
tension from different liquids.
So these are the
jaws of a micrometer,
and they're slowly stretched.
And this is a
droplet of pentane.
There is an action figure,
a bobblehead of Marie Curie,
in the background.
You can see the outline of her,
this beige background, and also
the image of her
focused in that droplet.
And so the students can use an
interactive measurement tool
to measure and compare surface
tension of different liquids
and from that develop their
understanding of intermolecular
forces.
So here, they have a
tutorial that helps
them develop and test models.
And ultimately, each section
of this activity, they expand.
There more and more liquids
they can do with it.
Interactive video allows
you to have perspective
you wouldn't be able to.
So here's a shot of a traffic
circle recorded with a drone.
One of [AUDIO OUT] amazed by is
these drones are unbelievable.
The video is so stable.
It looks like the drone
is bolted to the sky.
And again, with interactive
measurement tools
here, they could explore
coefficient of friction
that must exist between
the car tires and the road.
Things that are too
toxic or dangerous.
So here, students have
a choice of selecting
different substances
and quantities.
And in this case, this is going
to be mixed with water, sodium
hydroxide and water.
And then we also have
the ability for them
to not only lead a
temperature change
but see an infrared compared
with [INAUDIBLE] what
some of these reactions
are endothermic
and some exothermic.
And so they've got
a visualization.
John mentioned the tactile.
They miss that here.
They can't touch this liquid
and see that it's hot.
On the other hand, I'm not sure
that we would want them to.
And then one last affordance
of interactive video
that I'd like to point
out is time lapse.
So whereas in
physics, we often have
events that are
very short, so we
want to use slow
motion videography,
and in others, in
biology we often have
events that take a long time.
So here is a 10-day
long time lapse
of a terrarium that contains
some bean seeds and soil
and water.
We have a readout on top
of the carbon dioxide
level, the oxygen level,
and the temperature.
And over the first
four days, we can just
see that steadily the
oxygen is decreasing,
and the carbon
dioxide is increasing.
And that continues.
Boy, did I learn
a lot of biology
when we made this video.
The light cycle on and
off every 12 hours.
You still see the carbon
dioxide going, up even
though there are leaves.
And we also see that
plants grow and move
at night, which I did not know.
It's really not until we
get a really large selection
of leaves here on the seventh
day of this germination process
that we first see the
carbon dioxide go down.
This is a really fun question.
When we tested this, we gave it
to a group of pretty advanced
high school students
and asked them
to use this to collect evidence
that photosynthesis only
happens when the
lights are turned on.
And boy, was that a challenge
because almost all students,
rather than looking at
changes in gas level,
they just looked at gas levels.
So is the level of carbon
dioxide higher during the day,
for example, was a
question that they asked.
And so we really saw that the
ability to design experiments,
like what evidence do you
need to answer a question,
is something that
is readily available
with this interactive video.
So that's examples.
Pivot Interactives
is the company
that we have that
makes these available.
But interactive
video, in general,
we think is a very
powerful learning tool.
I look forward to the questions.
SAIF RAYYAN: Thank you.
Thank you, Peter.
I'm always amazed
looking at your videos.
Some of these studies
I haven't seen before.
And I love the level of
complexity of the activities
that you can actually
structure around it.
We have a lot of questions
in the chat, which
we'll reserve till the
end of the presentations.
But one quick
question, people are
asking if Pivot
Interactives is free
or if there is some
sort of an access
for underprivileged communities.
PETER BOHACEK: It's not free.
We worked on a model where
we could make it for free,
and we were not successful in
getting the funding that we
would need to develop
the tools, both
the videos and the software
platform that hosts it.
And so I can post in the
chat a link for the website.
And we wish it were.
We're a very small company.
I'm a teacher, and
my business partner,
who is a college professor,
started it ourselves.
And if we could figure
out a way to give it
to the world for free,
so if any of the people
here have that means
at their disposal
that they can help us give
it to the world for free,
we're ready.
We're not attached to
the commercial model.
It's just the only
one we know of that
allows us to scale this.
SAIF RAYYAN: Great.
And we'll continue
this discussion after.
Thank you, Peter.
PETER BOHACEK: Welcome.
SAIF RAYYAN: And
next, we're going
to hear from Jeannie about
her experience of moving
some of her labs to
become remote labs.
JEANNIE TALBOT: Hello.
My name's Jeannie Talbot.
I am the Physics Lab
Manager at University
of La Verne in California.
Let me share my screen.
So I am using a tool that
someone else created.
I use LabsLand, and
this is a recent use.
We had two weeks prep time.
How are we going to get
labs online in two weeks?
Nobody from my department had
ever done remote labs before.
Some of the other
departments were
using simulations, but those--
that platform wasn't
going to work for physics
because of content issues and
also because they weren't--
they didn't teach the how
to set up an experiment,
like Peter was talking about
and John touched on, as well.
So after my frantic
googling, I found LabsLand.
I was really impressed.
I was originally
drawn to the content.
They had the content
that we wanted to teach.
But this idea of having
a real laboratory
somewhere in the world
controlled via the internet
was really catchy.
So this is not all of the
things that they have,
but this is a sample.
The electronics labs
was really crucial
because second semester,
physics labs are needed.
We have to teach them how to
use certain equipment in order
for students to move on
and go to advanced labs.
And they had the
equipment that we needed
to train our students to use.
This is a screenshot
basically of the breadboard
that you can use in
the electronics lab.
So all these pieces on
the breadboard, students
can move them around, and
they can move the wires.
They can set up the pieces
that they want to put.
So they have some agency.
They can set up
their own experiment.
So if we ask them to come
up with a relationship
of the electricity flowing,
the voltage flowing
through a capacitor
in an RC circuit,
they can come up with their own.
And they can move around
the parts and try it out.
We have a whole
bunch of equipment
that they can look at.
They have multimeters,
function generators.
They have oscilloscopes
and a DC power supply.
And they can change
all the settings
on all of these things.
And learning to use these
pieces of equipment, especially
an oscilloscope, was really
crucial to our program
and how we were expecting
them to move on.
So the way that I set
it up within two weeks
was I just played
with their equipment
until I came up with
lab experiments.
And then I had to write
my own lab manuals.
There are some
resources out there
that don't make you
come up with anything.
You just take the equipment.
You take the program and
send it to your students.
And all you have to
mess with is grades.
This one, you have
a lot more control,
but you also have to do the
work of putting together
a manual, which I really
appreciated because it gave us
the flexibility to decide what
we needed for our students.
We ran three labs.
Two of them were
circuits labs, and one
was a radioactivity lab.
And the students were able to
do all of these experiments
almost the same way that
we would do them in person.
We still held video conferences
to have optional lab meetings.
And about half the
students showed up.
We didn't make it mandatory
because these are hard times.
And so in real-time,
if students set up
a problematic
breadboard, they could
ask for advice in real-time,
and that was really useful.
All the people would have
their own experiment up
on their own computers
and ask for advice.
And they could
share their screen
and whatnot and get advice.
The students who didn't
show up for those
had to do this through
email, but they were still
able to complete it
on their own time.
This was a big deal
for my department.
Our grading system is based
on lab notebooks for labs,
and that didn't have
to change for this.
We still use the same format.
Some of the students wrote
in their own lab notebook
from in-person labs,
and some of them
wrote in digital documents.
But we still had
the same rubric,
and we graded it the same way.
So that continuity was very
useful for my department.
So what we really
appreciated about labs
LabsLand was that it
was really consistent.
It created a format
that we could
keep most of our same lab
goals, and lab formats,
and grading, and structure
and just put it online.
We were able to train
them on equipment
that we need them to know
how to use in further years.
And also, we were
able to ask them
questions like, if
you wanted to see
the relationship
between these things,
how would you set this up?
And they would have the choices
to be able to put that together
in this environment.
The other thing that I really
appreciated was the real data.
The real data doesn't
match the theoretical.
And so it's-- they
were able to see that,
because they're looking
at a real oscilloscope.
And so they can find the
frequencies, et cetera,
that just don't quite
match with theory
and then consider what
might be happening
and think about what's
going on in a real lab
to create these discrepancies.
And for next time,
we are planning
to allow them to set up their
own experiments a little more.
In the interest of time, we
gave them canned experiments
because that was fast, but
we are able to think about--
so we could tell
the students, hey,
so you need to come up with a
relationship between distance
and the radioactive counts or
the thickness of the barrier
and compared to
radioactive counts.
How would you set
up this experiment?
And then they could just do
that based on what is available.
And so that's all I've
got on that front.
And I am looking forward to
whatever people might ask.
SAIF RAYYAN: Thank you, Jeannie.
That's a great presentation.
I really like how you
emphasized the fact
that you have to engage with
activities that are provided
by a certain product.
I know that there are a
lot of products out there.
If you have a package and you
just send it to the students,
you have no idea
what they're doing.
It's very hard to align
to your own goals.
So you still have to spend a
lot of time trying to figure out
pedagogically how to get
the learning goals that you
aim for using the product.
And I think what you provided
is a great example of how
that can work.
And that leads us--
a lot of questions
that are coming up, which
we'll ask the speakers later.
But several people are
asking about biology.
So, Bruce, can you
can you tell us
more about your experience
with virtual manufacturing?
BRUCE VAN DYKE: Yeah, of course.
Let me get some screen up here.
All right.
So I'm the Director, Founder and
Director of the Biotechnology
and Good Manufacturing
program at Quincy College
in Quincy, Mass.
We're just a few
miles south of Boston.
And our goal is to
train people to work
in the biopharmaceutical
industry as entry level
positions.
And that includes
gene and cell therapy,
which have come on
board very strongly
over the last few months.
And so we've developed, over the
last several years, a program
that we've been using it as
for teaching biomanufacturing
to students in a hybrid fashion.
So this is the entry
program to that.
And you come in here, and
these are introductory videos.
All of this is open source.
It's free to anyone
that wants to use it.
So you'll have access
to the link and log ins
to be able to use it.
And you come in here, and you're
going to hit the Start button.
And then I'm going to have
to kick out of my sharing
and bring up a new screen.
And from there,
it'll flow smoothly.
And so you just hit
the Start button,
and it's going to take
you into another screen,
and which I'm going
to show you now.
So I don't have a
PowerPoint here.
Let's see if I've
got the right one.
Yeah.
So this is real-time.
So it'll take you
into this screen.
And you can see up at the top,
there are different categories.
And so this is the workflow.
And then if we click over
here, and I'll come back
into workflow, you
can see that where
this for upstreaming for the
manufacturing of antibodies,
hormones, enzymes, whatever
the industry is producing.
And so it's broken
into modules, which
you can see you have buffer
and media prep on this side.
Then you go through
inoculation aspects.
And you can click
on certain things,
and it'll give you a little
picture of what's there
and what wave rockers
are all about.
So this is designed for
single-use manufacturing.
And so this just
introduces the students
to all the different
pieces of equipment
that are associated with that,
and into the bioreactors,
and then the bigger
bioreactors, and then
downstream just for harvesting.
But we don't really
have much on harvesting.
It's just to show you that's the
end of the upstream processing.
And so the academic heart of it
is over here in the workflow,
and I'll show you
what I mean by that.
And so we do-single use.
And because of that,
we're using bags.
Everything's done
in sterile bags.
This is the buffer
and media prep part.
It goes from media prep, through
inoculation, and expansion,
production, and harvesting.
And you can see the breakdown
in these different areas
by hitting the
arrows on the right.
I'm not going to go
into all of this.
And then once you get it
made-- so this is the process
the industry uses.
All of this was designed.
I started working in the
industry about 10 years ago.
And they helped me
lay out all of this.
And then ATeL
Learning, e-learning,
does all the programming for us.
And I'll tell you a
little about that company.
We've been working together
for about 15 years.
But you get down here to
the inoculation steps.
And this is what we
do with our students.
They start with 250
milli shake flasks.
They're going to learn all
about media prep and so forth.
You hit the side
arrows, and it gives you
a breakdown of the process,
where you can see the--
and you have the media addition.
Notice you're going
to get information
in the right-hand
panel [INAUDIBLE]
ask you what each
of these are about.
And then so you--
over here is all about
getting the media ready to go,
equilibrating it.
Always have to validate
something's clean
before you do an inoculation.
Moving into the
inoculation aspect,
and this tells you about
cell densities, viable cell
densities you want to start
with and all about sampling
the group, what's going on.
And then you go
into the incubating.
And for the little
shake flasks they're
going to shake in
incubators, just CO2 input.
And these are all the
outputs that you can get.
And all those have to be tested.
And that goes on from there.
My students go from there.
And we do this in the lab.
So we have all the
equipment in the lab,
and then this
student have to work
through all of these
processes before they
do anything in the lab.
I'll introduce it to them.
They go home, work
through the virtual,
and then they come into the
lab and begin to do things.
And it saves me about 40%
of my time because they're
working with the same type
of equipment virtually
that we use in the lab.
So from here, they'll go
down to a 2-liter wave bag.
And the process is the
same, except there's
a little difference
because you're scaling up
from one flask to another.
And so you get more
information about how
to do all that scaling.
And this goes on and on.
And so that's the workflow.
And I've had to use this.
So we shut down the
college just about the time
they were getting ready to
actually do the scale up
of a million cells to
produce an antibody.
So they had to use this.
And so we quickly
switched through this,
and it showed all the
failings of the program, which
we quickly would
make adjustments
to get things better and develop
a lot of supplementary material
for.
And then we would go from there.
But these are all just
the academic side.
So a hands-on side is--
the interactive side is
what I want to show you.
And so we've got
bee labs up here,
and you can see inoculation and
cell growth and cell counting.
Let me just start with
the cell counting,
and you have a tutorial
and a practice.
Now, the tutorial is
going to just take
you step by step on how to
work in a tissue culture lab
for doing-- working
with mammalian cells.
This takes you through the prep.
And I'm just going to skip
that so you can see something
a little more.
And you're going to get in.
Ultimately, you're
going to learn
how to use-- how to
prepare cells for counting.
You can see what
this is all about.
Up here-- well, I'm in the
tutorial, so I can't do that.
So I'm going to go back and go
into the actual practice mode
so you can actually
see me doing something.
But the students go step by
step through the tutorial
to understand the process.
And then they go in, and they
have to do this all themselves.
And so, again, I'll skip that
because that takes a long time,
but that teaches the
basic on how to prepare
cells for cell counting.
And so you've got
instructions over
on the bottom right-hand side.
And now you can come up
here, and these cells
are going to grow for
different numbers of days.
And you can go through
whatever you would like to do.
And if you take it on day
two, and you get this,
you can see the cell
density is increased.
But the nice thing is that you
can get close and actually see
them.
You can move this around to
do the counting of the cells
in the different quadrants.
All right.
So this is the first quadrant
in our-- in this program,
in our lab, we
counted four quadrants
around a hemocytometer.
Actually, we have automated cell
counters at school in the lab,
but the students have
to learn both ways.
The thing is we--
you count cells.
For us, you can't cells at
the top and on the right
but not on the
bottom and the left.
And so you literally
go through here,
and you start selecting
cells that are viable.
You notice here, right
now we're in non-viable.
So I would have been
doing that wrong.
Well, we're in viable.
So we do this, this.
And when you go
through it, you're
going to put it in a number.
Then you're going to shift over
and do non-viable and click
the ones that are.
And it's going to tally
them all up down here.
When you get done,
you could move
over the calculation screen.
It's going to show you how
to do all the calculations.
And so that's how that
piece of the lab works.
If we go into the
inoculation side,
and I'll do the tutorial just
because we're running quickly,
here's our tissue culture lab.
And so you can see
it's got everything
you need from incubators,
to a minus 150
storage facility, water baths,
centrifuge, microscopes,
biosafety cabinets, everything.
And so if you want
to run through it,
you hit the Start button.
It's going to tell
you what to do.
On the bottom panel,
turn on the water baths
at the temperature to 37.
And then you just start
clicking the Forward buttons.
And this is cleaning
the biosafety cabinet.
And then on and on through
this whole process.
And I'm going to try to click
through these quickly, get
cells out of here.
And here comes this magical
glove that hangs in the air,
and then you get a vial
out of the minus 50,
you put in the water bath.
Now, you're going
to take, put it back
into the biosafety cabinet.
And now you're going
to start preparing.
You're going to
take those cells,
and you're going to run
them through a whole process
so that you can set
up a shake flask
or whatever you want to do.
All right.
So now we're back.
So now, first, so we
looked at cell counting,
just a little bit
about inoculation.
And then you go
into cell growth.
And if we would
go into here, this
is where the whole
thing happens.
So in our program
when teaching people,
we scale up from 250 shake
flask, to 2-liter wave bags,
into 10-liter bioreactor bags
to produce these drug products.
Then we do all the
harvesting and validations.
So this, again, is the tutorial.
And if you hit the
Start button down here,
it's going to show you how
some disposable bag gets loaded
into a 2000-meter reactor.
And it's going to set up
the whole process for what
it takes to actually scale
up into these larger vessels.
And then, if you hit--
again, you get the--
this, it's going to take you
through the whole process
about how much media you
have put in, how much seed,
which are viable cells,
and so forth and so on.
And so then, once the
students step through this,
and they'll get instructions
along the way, the same thing,
they're going to have to
go in and do it themselves.
And my students just
did all this actually.
We've got batch records
just like the industry uses.
I send out the batch records
to [AUDIO OUT] vessels
and then scaling up
through all the process,
and they're learning it.
So you can see,
you open the door.
We're going to put the bag in.
And believe me, it's not that
easy to load a 2000-liter bag
into these reactors.
We're going to close
the door, and it's
going to move into
this particular mode.
We're going to hit
the-- if I can move this
up just a little bit.
I'm sorry about this.
Doesn't quite fit my screen.
Start the process.
And now, if we come over
here, now the students
have to put or assemble
the whole thing together,
just like they'd have
to do in the lab.
They have to set
up all the gases,
they have to set up all of the
base, the acid, the antifoam,
whatever they're going to
do to get this reactor up
and running.
And it's a long process,
but it works really well.
I mean, they really enjoy it,
and it's the second best thing
to doing it in the lab.
And so, of course,
they're disappointed
we haven't been able to do this
aspect fortunately in bio man,
this is more of an advanced
manufacturing course.
We do the same thing with
microbial manufacturing.
We don't use this program.
Everyone knows microbes grow
fast, mammalian cells don't.
And so we can run-- in a
week, we can run through
the mammalian--
I mean, no, bacterial
[INAUDIBLE]..
So what I want to do is just
to close this up, sharing this,
and share some other
resources with you
that are also available.
Let's go to all.
So this is the website
for the programmer
that does all work for me.
His name is Yakov Churner.
Here is our virtual
biomanufacturing lab,
and he's done
others you can see.
He built this for a lab
at MIT, this X-ray lab.
And you can see
classical mechanics
for doing golf and so forth.
There's a lot of resources
here that he's built out.
And he and I have been working
together, as I mentioned,
for about 15 years.
So there's a lot to be done.
And we're still working.
We're working on
augmented reality
right now for some of these
virtual labs that we're doing.
And let me show you
one other resource that
would be very useful.
Anyway, I can't
find it right now,
so I won't be able to
share that with you.
But there is an organization.
It's called InnovATE with
A-T-E in capitals, InnovATEBIO.
It is the National
Science Foundation
Center for Biotechnology.
And so I've done a couple
webinars on their website.
We'll put those-- give
those resources, too,
so make those resources
available to you.
And there is all
kinds of tools there
from things that are useful
for high school students
or any level of
college students.
And so it's highly functional.
All of them are
free, open source.
And you'll be able to find
the webinar I did for what
I've just been showing you now.
And I did another one
on protein purification,
which is not our virtual lab,
but it was built by AG Booth.
He's a professor at Leeds
University in London.
And he developed
this program in 1998.
It's powerful for teaching
protein purification.
And so there's a
webinar up there
for that, as well, if that
would be interesting and many
other site types.
So I look forward
to your questions.
It's exciting to be here.
And thank you for listening.
KIRKY DELONG: Thank you.
SAIF RAYYAN: Thank you, Bruce.
I'll hand it over to Kirky.
You have a lot of interesting
questions, great questions,
and I'm looking forward
to the discussion.
KIRKY DELONG: Great questions.
I'm going to start with some
questions for anybody just
to get these out there.
Towards the end of this,
there's been a lot of questions
about the future plans.
Is the experience
going online going
to change how you
teach going forward?
They understand
the need to react
in the current situations.
But if similar constraints come
up in the fall, what are you
planning for?
What might you do differently
in the fall with the extra time
to plan and learn from what
you've done this spring,
anybody?
JOHN LIU: Sure.
I can offer two or three things.
The first thing is
now-- first of all, now
after seeing-- trying it once,
I think the instructors have all
seen how important it is to
start with the question, what
are your learning
goals, and then
to go through that whole loop.
We've all seen it
in one iteration,
but now we've seen what
works and what doesn't.
Often, it's easy to just get
caught up with this transition.
This is what I can do,
or that is what I can do.
But if you start
with that question,
it will lead you to
a very good path.
The second thing is it's
actually very difficult,
to be honest, to say to plan
for the fall, because MIT,
and I would assume most
institutions right now,
haven't actually decided on what
the fall is going to look like.
And at MIT, we're really
considering the full range
almost, as students on
campus, to partially,
to completely students
not on campus.
But what I can say is that
around virtual collaboration,
so as you can see, students
could see the experiments much
more if the model was on
campus, and they could see it
from their screen, or
collaboration around Dropbox
or other software packages.
Those often would
tighten the loop
of how people work together.
There's other areas in
analysis and simulation
where instructors, we were
finding that students could
learn a lot more deeply because
they could see much more not
obfuscated by the
physical model.
In simulations, you can see
a lot more the direct link
between cause and
effect, input and output.
And so that was also a
learning that we wanted
to implement in the fall.
KIRKY DELONG: Anybody else?
PETER BOHACEK: Two
things I've noticed.
One, I think that there's an
increased need for student
feedback that in the past, as
we interacted with our students
in a face to face, there's
lots of casual feedback
that you just walk by a student
that's working on something.
And you notice
what they're doing,
or maybe you offer a comment.
But I really acutely
notice this difference
where you can't see them,
and they can't see you.
And so you can't see their work.
And I think as an instructor,
but I think also as a student,
it's disconcerting.
And so I think
coming up with ways
to be able to give frequent
feedback, hopefully
automated feedback, I think
as these systems are virtual,
and as they develop, if we
can come up with better ways
that as the students
are working,
it can give them hints about
whether they're doing things
right.
And then just being--
I have found that my
attention has turned towards,
when students are working
something, like I look at it
and write to them.
And that feedback
seems to really help.
So that's one
thing I've noticed.
And the other is I
think that there's still
a need for better tools to allow
students to collaborate freely.
So for example, breakout
rooms, that sort of thing
is the right idea.
I don't know if we're
quite there yet.
I just think we need
more work on how
students can
spontaneously group or can
be grouped by instructors.
I really acutely feel that
missing in my own instruction,
students being able to work
in groups or two or three
or share across groups.
This group of two or
three hears something
or sees something
another group is doing.
We need better tools for that.
KIRKY DELONG: Bruce?
BRUCE VAN DYKE: So what
we've been looking at
are trying to develop more
resources for this being
able to actually evaluate
how well the students are
able to learn from
the virtual labs.
And we're working intensively
on that in the background
with that National Science
Foundation training
organization I mentioned to you.
So we have some assessments
up there, but there--
takes a lot of time
to build them out.
And that takes money, which
is hard to get for people.
It's easy to get a
lot of grant money
for equipment and
supplies and so forth,
but to get money for people
is sometimes challenging.
But we have now met
this other organization.
Well, it's going to
help us build out
a lot of those type resources.
Also, we track people.
Our programs can track what
the students are doing,
if they're--
how active they are
on the virtual labs,
whether or not they're having
to repeat over and over
or whether or not they're
catching things quickly
and being able to move through.
And another thing
is something we've
been thinking about
for about three years,
and we're actually working
on now, is just what Peter
was just talking
about, a build out room
where you can see everybody.
And you can have
intense discussions
about whatever it is.
They can talk about what the
problems are in real-time.
We actually have
industry people said
they'd come in
and work with them
through some of these
different aspects,
as well, so that we didn't
have to do all the work.
So we hope to have that.
I'm working with the programmer,
Yakov Churner, and his company
to try to get this
also online as quickly
as we can to make it more
effective for the students
to be able to work in real-time
and understand the processes
that they're doing.
KIRKY DELONG: Thank you.
Jeannie?
JEANNIE TALBOT: Thanks, Bruce.
That's really good thoughts.
I haven't spent
much time thinking
about how we're
going to get students
to interact with each other.
That's something I
should probably do.
I've been asked to provide
plans for going forward,
not only just all the way
back to on campus labs
and on campus, but we can
only have half of them
in the room or a third
of them in the room.
And so thinking about if
we are on campus, how we're
going to keep all the
lab experiments going
while only allowing them in
the room a third of the time.
And also, we need to
have a plan for if we
need to send them home again
or if we don't ever come back.
We're working on
all these plans.
And I want to reiterate
what John was saying.
All of my department is putting
an emphasis on our learning
goals and how we can do
better with our learning goals
in all of those situations.
KIRKY DELONG: Thank you.
And I agree.
That's very important,
especially given this,
we don't know what the situation
is with students at home.
One of the questions that's
come up over and over again
is around, can you use
these for guided inquiry,
or problem-based learning,
or project-based learning?
Have anybody tried some of that?
Can you share your experiences?
BRUCE VAN DYKE: Well, I
don't know if it's really
any different than
what I've already said,
but students have these projects
that are enormous projects,
to start with a vial
minus 150 in freezer,
and taking that out, and
ending up with a protein,
purified validated protein
product, at the end.
I mean, they're huge processes
and very time-consuming.
And that's basically
what the virtual lab
is training them to do.
That's what they
do in real-time,
obviously, when
they're in the lab.
So in this case,
so that virtual lab
is designed to be project-based.
It can be modular.
If you just want to learn tissue
culture and how to grow cells,
prepare cells for whatever
you want to do with them,
that's there.
So I haven't really been able
to think beyond that yet,
but obviously there
is a big need.
KIRKY DELONG: Thanks.
Anybody else doing any group
work, or problem-based,
or a guided inquiry
with the labs?
JOHN LIU: I think one of the
iterations that we've tried
is-- so I think about what I
recall is in elementary school,
there's the whole put
together a PB and J sandwich.
So one person has--
is the hands, and the
other person is the talker.
And they have to
give instructions,
and the first person
just puts it together.
And the first person
usually is the teacher.
And so the student will say, put
the peanut butter on the bread.
And it's clunk.
And that kind of model
we've been exploring
for guided inquiry because
what you can do then
is if, for example,
the staff can
be the one in front
of the experiment,
they can say, OK, what--
students, what do
you want me to do--
turn this nob or
place this on here?
And, of course, the
main learning goal
isn't precise communication
or for instructions
like it would be
for PB and J, but it
would be guided discovery
because it's kind
of like choose your adventure.
You want to do this?
OK.
Well, then let's
continue down that rabbit
hole in this particular
experiment exploration.
So that's one way
we've thought about it.
The other way is, as
I mentioned, kits.
So if you're able
to, if you think
about a particular phenomenon,
if you can break it
up or simplify it,
perhaps you can actually
send it over if it's safe
to the students' homes.
And then you can think through.
You can host a Zoom session
and walk each step through them
in a Socratic way.
All of them are
working through it,
and they can discuss
like, oh, I saw this.
And then the classmates
can converge and synthesize
their observations.
And then you can continue to
take them on the next step.
So if the materials
can be sent home,
then they also get that tactile
sense in their guided inquiry.
Kirky, you also asked about
project-based learning.
What we found, I mentioned the
example about play-based design
and where students are putting
together their own board games.
So what we found is
the learning goal here
is really about closing the loop
between ideation, prototyping,
user testing, and then back,
back to the second prototype,
and going through
that whole loop.
And so if that's
your learning goal,
you don't necessarily
have to have--
we do, we certainly
do have pretty --
a very built out fabrication
machine shop for the toy design
course.
But if that's your
learning goal,
there's actually a lot
of things that you can
play with when you're at home.
And so we found that when we're
sticking with that learning
goal, we can come up
with, we send you foam,
and you just cut it up
with an X-Acto knife.
And we send you balsa
wood, and you can--
and markers.
And you can still put together a
game that tests your main ideas
and allows you to
perform that loop.
And so I'd offer
that as an example
that perhaps you
can think through,
what's the main learning
goal of your project course,
and is that something that
you can transfer over?
If there are areas that you
really can't, like the Segway
kit, perhaps there
are ways that you
can think about contracting
out the fabrication,
different pieces
of the fabrication,
sending them a base kit.
Not everyone needs
to-- they don't all
need to speck out
their own Arduino kit.
You could send them all
something like that.
And then some of our
classes, we're giving them
a small budget that-- it
depends on, of course,
also the age range
of your students.
But if we had grad
students or upperclassmen,
we give them a budget,
and they could manage it.
Or it's you sending them
a bill of materials,
and they get to compose
their materials,
and you can order for them.
KIRKY DELONG: Anybody else
want to make a comment?
Or I'll ask the next question.
OK.
So the next question,
there's a group of them
around the experience.
What feedback are you
getting from the students
about the new virtual
experiences versus what
they experienced in the lab?
Are the development
competencies similar?
Are you seeing any
differences with that?
So what are you guys seeing?
Go ahead, Jeannie.
JEANNIE TALBOT: Great.
At La Verne, we tried to keep
it as smooth as possible.
Our feedback has been
that they appreciated--
not too many students
responded to the feedback.
But they said that they
appreciated how consistent it
was based on what we were doing
before and so that we could
move through and
have the same grading
policy that we
had before, and we
can have the same style of lab.
So that was nice.
I think that was the main
comment, was the consistency.
KIRKY DELONG: Go ahead, Bruce.
BRUCE VAN DYKE: So what
I found was that it
seems that when students--
well, let me say
that after I did
the webinar for
the organization,
and there were
about 85 professors
from around the country on
that, they all liked it,
and they're working
with students on that.
But what we find is that,
even though we have the step
by step instructions on
the site, a lot of people
don't like to read instructions.
You buy something from
IKEA, and you bring it home.
And you just try to assemble it
without reading instructions.
Well, they go into these
virtual labs, and they try to--
they want to play with them.
So they just start playing
without getting instructions,
and they get lost.
And so we're trying to--
those that once you've
instructed them and say, listen,
just before you play too much,
just try stepping through it
so you understand the process.
And once you've got that,
then you go back and play
with them whenever you want.
And when it doesn't work,
you'll know why it doesn't work,
and you can go back
and readjust things.
And so that's one
of the issues that
has arisen as we try
to get students online.
My students just do it because
they work with me all the time,
whereas new people
coming into it,
they get a little
lost until they get
a little further instruction.
KIRKY DELONG:
Peter, any comment?
PETER BOHACEK: Yeah, I do.
So as far as students'
opinions of them
and their reaction to them,
we notice that students
have different preferences.
So we noticed that when students
are doing hands-on labs,
that often they are worried
about whether they're doing it
right, whether they are--
appreciate the fact
that, if they're
doing an interactive video lab
that they know they can go back
and repeat their measurement
if they make a mistake.
But we also notice
that there are students
who say they really
like, and of course we
can understand that, touching
and feeling the equipment.
So as far as students' opinions
of it, we see a variety.
But when we moved this
product before we started
building Pivot
Interactives, we did a test
to see, what are they learning?
Regardless of what they
think they're learning,
what are they actually
learning specifically
around model building
and model evaluation,
which are two of the core
things that are interested in?
And so I'm going to
post in there a paper
that we published
about just that,
over a semester-long study.
And that was for
us the green light
that we should build
this because we could
see that students really were
learning the kinds of science
practices we hoped they were.
So I'll put that in there.
KIRKY DELONG: Thank you.
OK.
So we have a follow
on question to that.
As an instructor, how can
I use one of the products
and know that the students are
actually using them and not
just copying?
What do you guys think?
JOHN LIU: Well, I
think this is why
it's so important to have
a real direct connection
with your students.
We're actually
spending a lot of time
right now discussing,
what are the best
formats for assessment,
and especially
as we approach the
final exam this time
and thinking about fall exam.
And one of the things that
has really popped out to me
is the power of oral exams.
As a teacher, you can probably
spend 5, 10, 15 minutes,
a very short time,
with a student
and get a pretty good
idea of what they do
and they don't understand.
And especially
during a time when
the one to one, the person
to person interaction
is so important,
you can consider
placing in other kinds of
activities, like small group
discussions or one to one
interviews on those activities
so that you can have a deeper
sense of what they really
do know or don't know.
And you'd be surprised at
how much more seriously
students take it when you
actually are going to say, hey,
I'm going to follow
up with you in person.
That really forces them or
motivates them to really think
that they know, because if--
they can hide behind
an assignment.
But they can't really
hide in front of you.
I did also want to
circle back to, Kirky,
your previous question.
Just one note about
the student experience.
We're Mechanical Engineering.
We probably have one of the
most hands-on activities
in the school.
I think about half
of our courses,
and we have 500 undergrads
and 400 grad students.
So there was definitely a
sense of loss in the beginning
where students were
saying, hey, I signed up.
I enrolled into MIT for this
course, to build a robot
or to build.
And so we had to manage that in
a way that, one, to demonstrate
that we feel them
as instructors.
We really do cherish
hands-on activities.
That's partly the reason
why a lot of us are there.
And two, I think this
is really important
to consider, to not think of
your students as a consumer
but to think of them as a
partner in the transition.
We surveyed them right
in the beginning.
And we said-- across
many of our courses.
And we asked them, what
are you going to miss?
What are the things that
you really want to get?
For example, in my class, we
were just in the middle of--
we were just about to start
manufacturing the yo-yos.
And a lot of them said, I
don't have any feel of my yo-yo
even though I spent so
much time designing it.
And so in the last week
that we had on campus,
the technical instructors were
spending 10 plus hour days
just pumping out
different yo-yo parts so
that we could send
them to students.
So at least they had--
they could hold
onto something that
represented their design work.
And then in the midway
in the transition,
we pulled them again.
And we can iterate,
reiterate on that process.
We're a big fan of continuous
improvement in manufacturing.
That's the concept we teach,
and we can apply that also
in our teaching.
KIRKY DELONG: Thank you.
Anybody else?
JEANNIE TALBOT: So
this is not as--
I think following up in person
is a really, really good way
to do it.
Our lab instructors
have been trying
to do that with all
our students, for sure.
Another thing that we
do with the LabsLand
is that we are alerted whenever
a student completes or attempts
one of the activities.
And so we can see that
they've attempted it.
So if they turn
in a lab notebook,
and we can see that they
haven't even done it,
then we can have a
discussion with the student.
But also, that allows us to see,
well, you've done the activity,
but you haven't turned
in the lab notebook.
And so we can talk to that
student about what's going on.
KIRKY DELONG: Bruce,
did you have a comment?
BRUCE VAN DYKE: Well, as I
mentioned, we can monitor them.
I can.
Other people using the program
cannot because it's not
available for other people
to see the activity.
It's only available through
the programmer and his company.
And since he and I
interact all the time,
I get feedback on
that all the time.
I do know that we've gotten
a lot of positive feedback
on people using this as to being
able to assess whether or not
my students, especially
my advanced students,
whether or not they
really picked up
the understanding
of the process.
Their exams are quite long
there, for them there,
because it's all about
process, and they
have to go through all that.
We've got finals next week.
And so they've actually
already had some lab
practical finals not in the lab.
And they've been online.
So it's still a challenge to be
able to assess, apart from just
the exams that I send.
And, of course, we don't
have and didn't have time
to set it up so
that you can prove
they're not cheating
because they've
got all the books with them.
I know they have a
lot of integrity,
the students that I
work with, but again,
for this first round,
we just have to--
we're winging it to try
to get the assessment.
But for the fall if this
happens again, we are--
as I mentioned, we're really
trying to build out ways
to be able to test
them in real-time,
such as what John talked
about, face to face telling me
what they understand
about a certain process.
KIRKY DELONG: Thank you.
We had a question
directed at Peter.
Have you thought about creating
a virtual workshop for teachers
to play with the
tools and teach them
how to create their
own similar labs?
PETER BOHACEK:
That's a great idea.
Yes.
To make their own
similar labs, like one
of the things I've always
wanted to share but never really
had a forum to do it is
how to make these videos,
because it's hard.
And I don't mind
sharing about that.
There certainly are
an infinite number
of things that can
be recorded and never
even scratch the surface.
But we haven't ever really done
that, but I would invite people
if they want to
contact me directly,
and they have
specific questions.
As far as coming up with ways
specifically to use our tools,
so for example, you
can use our tools
to create your--
upload your own videos
and build activities
around those.
Our website has a fair
amount of instruction
about how to do that.
But I really would like to
build more of a community.
It's something that
we're working on,
more of a community.
Of course it would be great to
make a really broad community
of everybody.
But I mean specifically
of our users
because it would be
more focused on what
you can do with our tools.
And so that's a great suggestion
that we haven't really
developed yet but something
that we're working on.
KIRKY DELONG: Thank you.
John, we had a question for you.
How much tech/TA help was
available and needed to put
the 30 labs online at
MIT in the two weeks?
And how did you guys
think about this?
JOHN LIU: We didn't sleep.
It took a lot of work.
At that kind of time
scale, we do not
have time to hire in
or bring in extra help.
It's simply whoever
is part of that team
initially, you made
do with what you have.
So if you had a TA,
great if you did.
Most of our lab classes have
one or two TAs, I would say.
For the large
project classes, we
might also have two to
four technical instructors
in addition to a lead
lecturer or a lead professor
for that class.
But in the summer,
certainly, we're
thinking many faculty
take off the summer,
or instructors have
nine-months appointments.
So that is something that
we're considering, as well.
But that's a real constraint.
This is why I
shared about, what's
your workload going
to be when you think
about the different models?
That's definitely something
you've got to think through.
KIRKY DELONG: Thank you.
Jeannie, similar
question to you.
As you were getting
this through,
what did it take to get this
all set up for the students?
JEANNIE TALBOT: Well,
once I found the platform,
it didn't take too much.
Like I said in my slides, I
just looked at the experiments
they had available.
And some of the circuits
that we do in lab they
didn't have available.
So I looked at what they had.
I messed with it until
I found something
that would work
as a replacement,
teach you something similar.
And I wrote a lab manual
based off what we already
had and told them to do it.
It took about a week
to write the lab
and then send it out
to the lab instructors
and make sure that it
included everything that they
felt we should include.
And then back to testing
with our teaching assistants,
they made sure that
there were no bugs.
It really didn't take too long.
The only thing that I
wish that we'd done better
is allowed students
more decision
over what was happening
with the circuits.
KIRKY DELONG: Thank you.
Bruce, we had a question
about VR that you mentioned
and how you're doing
augmented reality.
Is it a web
interface, or does it
involve something more
advanced or some hardware
that they have to have?
BRUCE VAN DYKE: No, you
can use it on your phone.
So it'll work on any device.
We're not ready
to launch it yet,
but you can-- the virtual
lab I was showing you,
you can use it on your phone.
It works on any type of device.
So students aren't limited.
The augmented reality
will be the same.
I can demo it to
different people,
but nobody can use it yet.
But it will eventually
be usable on any device.
But right now, it's still
in the development stages.
But you'll be able to--
if you're in a classroom
or wherever you are,
people will be able
to interact, be
able to manipulate all of
these devices, all these bio
processing devices as if you're
in it, as if you're walking
and you're in it.
And so it's exciting still,
but we're still developing it.
So it's going to take a
little more time and money.
JOHN LIU: Bruce, I think it's
really exciting that you're
using augmented reality
to bring, transport
the student into
the environment,
because especially,
even in non-COVID days,
sometimes it's difficult to
bring them into commercial
or research context.
BRUCE VAN DYKE: Yeah.
And we're actually going
to be able to take them
inside the reactors,
in a sense, to be
able to see what's going on.
JOHN LIU: That's awesome.
BRUCE VAN DYKE: We've got a
lot of ideas we're working on,
and they're all very practical.
They just take money to be
able to develop them fully,
but we're working on that.
So we've got some money from
National Science Foundation,
and the State of Massachusetts,
and an organization
called Nimble.
So we're working
on this, not just
for the biopharma but for the
gene cell therapy companies.
JOHN LIU: If you're
interested in manufacturing,
I just launched a MITx
course, Fundamentals
of Manufacturing Processes.
And we're about to release
augmented reality for that
because it's really
important for us
to be able to
disassemble products
and to do different things about
the process and its product
assembly.
So if you're interested
in how-- we actually
have a very similar
approach to Bruce,
because we think that
augmented reality
shouldn't just be
available to people
who can afford $3,000
headsets, but you
should be able to use
it on your cell phone.
So you can roll in the edX
course for free, Fundamentals
of Manufacturing Processes.
And I think we're releasing
our first augmented reality
experience in a few weeks.
It'll be surrounding the
analysis of casting products,
like pipe fittings and whatnot.
But afterwards, in a
few weeks after that,
then we'll be disassembling
an Amazon Fire Tablet.
BRUCE VAN DYKE: Oh, great!
I'd love to see it.
Send me the link.
JOHN LIU: I will.
BRUCE VAN DYKE: Great!
JOHN LIU: I'll send it now.
KIRKY DELONG: Bruce,
quick follow on question.
Is there a paper describing
your VR experiences?
Have you written one yet?
BRUCE VAN DYKE: No, but I have
a lot of information about--
well, first of all, there
have been some publications
about the development of
the virtual lab, what's
going on behind the scenes
for all the cyber stuff
and so forth.
But as far as for the use
of it, we haven't actually
written a paper on that.
KIRKY DELONG: We're
running out of time.
I'm going to do one
more question here.
We have a whole
series of questions
about rubric and
assessment tools
and how they are
different for real
versus virtual laboratories.
People have mentioned face
to face tools and grading lab
notebooks.
What other tools are you guys
using or have you been using?
BRUCE VAN DYKE: Batch records.
They have to fill
them out just as
if they're in the lab
every step of the way.
So that's obviously
a tool that we use,
and it's complex, but yeah.
So the students all just sent
me their batch records and all
of their data sheets and
environmental monitoring
aspects and so forth.
KIRKY DELONG: John?
Peter?
JOHN LIU: Gradescope.
I was just in a
discussion about this.
The nice thing
about Gradescope is
that, so there's a
rubric, rubrics that are--
rubric functionality
that's implemented in it.
Students can upload it
within different times,
and then multiple people can
grade the same assignment
to get uniform grading.
And then, let's
say you grade 10,
and then you realize,
oh you know what,
I weighted this one too much.
You can go back to
the rubric, adjust it,
and it will retroactively apply
across all your assignments.
You do have to think about--
with hands-on, you do--
labs and whatnot, you do have
to rethink because your learning
goals have shifted.
And you've probably-- you've
hopefully strategically focused
your learning goals on
the few that you really
think are important and
that you want to do.
And so your rubric really
should reflect that shift.
KIRKY DELONG: Thank you.
I think that's everything, guys.
Lots of questions.
Thank you, everybody,
for attending.
Thank you to our
wonderful speakers.
We really enjoyed learning
about your experiences,
and you've given
us amazing ideas.
But thank you, guys, very much.
And thank you to all of
our great guest speakers.
BRUCE VAN DYKE: Thank you.
JOHN LIU: Thank you so much.
SAIF RAYYAN: Thank you.
Thank you, John.
Thank you, Bruce.
Thank you, Jeannie.
BRUCE VAN DYKE: Nice
meeting you all.
SAIF RAYYAN: Thank you, Peter.
BRUCE VAN DYKE:
Great to meet you.
SAIF RAYYAN: This was fantastic.
BRUCE VAN DYKE: I look
forward to getting your link.
JOHN LIU: Thank you very much.